hello everybody welcome back to the next
episode of the SCP P for school
assignments where we're basically going
through all the labs in order on this
website and yeah you can find them just
right here at this site see fat beaver
school.com slash assignments and well
it's just got a weird
cutoff side but basically we're up to
set three now and it looks like this is
just one program and it wants us to
write a program that takes length as
input and feet and inches
and then the program should convert the
lengths into centimeters and display it
on the screen assume that the given
length and feet and inches are integers
okay so no fractions and the feet
integers okay based on the problem you
need to design an algorithm as follows
get the lengths and feet and inches
convert the lengths and to total inches
convert the total inches and to
centimeters and then output the
centimeters now it also mentions it the
formula is you need to multiply the
total inches by two point five four
instead of using two point five four
directly in the program and you declare
it as a constant and same thing you want
to do for number of inches and feet
declare as a constant so just some
standard stuff that you should do in a
program I guess we're gonna learn a
little bit about constants and looks
like it says to write the complete
length conversion program follow these
steps begin a program with comments for
documentation I'm probably going to skip
some of that since I'm talking about it
here include header file then you're
used in the program of course yeah it's
a weird thing declare name constants if
any write the definition in function
main include header fire pulse if any
are used in the program this is an
assumption if you're using something if
you don't include you're gonna get an
error so I don't know why they even
state this but I guess it's just because
you're learning and maybe forgot or
something but yeah obviously if you're
using something then
you need to pull from header you you
have no option but to include it or it
just won't work so that's kind of a
weird step to say like it's something
you just need to do alright so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna go into
our labs folder and if we look at this
we know we don't have var set three yet
because well we're just starting now so
we're gonna do a make der to make the
directory bars set three we're gonna go
into VARs set three and we're gonna
we're gonna touch a main.cpp and a
makefile and now we should see those so
we can do code on this folder and that
will open visual studio code for us and
we can get straight to business so we
can look at our main looking at make
file I wanna make file let's just make a
default and all its gonna do is compile
with G plus plus and main.cpp and then
afterwards we will go ahead and just run
it so we run it right away I think it's
gonna be called a dot exe so that if we
just type make it'll compile our main
and then it will attempt to run it so
that just makes a little easier once
we're done here alright so of course
we're going to need I Oh stream input
output stream and of course we need a
main now we want to go ahead and put our
constants in here so we want let's do a
float I'm going to do these in caps so
two meters let me just look at these
again to make sure I'm doing them right
multiply total inches by two put forward
yet very good centimeters I'm just gonna
call it centimeters per inch and that's
going to equal 2.5 4 and it wants this
to be a constant so what we can do here
is just put a constant in the front
right here and we want another Const
float actually I think this one's going
to be an integer yes ensure this is
basically only inches per foot inches
per foot and this of course is 12 there
are 12 inches in a foot so there we got
our constants as it wanted us to do and
now we can just go ahead and write our
program we just need to take in a few
things we'll do some C outs here I could
do using namespace standard so I don't
have to do this all the time but I'm
just used to doing it this way so it'll
be fine so let's go ahead and ask or
we'll give a little documentation at the
top and what the program does
so the user for the user when they run
it converting feet inches to send him to
the meters put a new line there we'll
make it like we're really excited and
put some exclamation points there and
then we want to do another one and we'll
just say enter feet and then we'll do a
CN of our feet of course we need to
declare the variable for feet so we're
gonna do a integer feet now these
constants I have outside the main they
can actually be in the main since we're
just going to operate all from the scope
of this main here so we'll just do that
we'll go ahead and put our feet up here
we're go ahead and put inches up here
and we will default these to zero when
the program starts just because we can
format that and these are the wrong
direction for CN of course and then we
want to do a similar thing I'm just
gonna copy these two lines real quick I
do that one you highlight something
press ctrl D it copies it so this one we
wanted to say inter inches inches and
then we'll after that's all done we want
to go to our algorithm and process the
rest so let's see if feet is greater
than zero you know it doesn't really
mention a few things here but basically
we don't want to allow negative numbers
because that makes no sense you can't be
negative feet length really that just
just makes no sense so I'm gonna put it
feet is greater than zero we're gonna
process um I'll say greater than or
equal just so it's not negative it can
be zero though that makes sense for it
to be zero and then we're just going to
say yeah we'll just go through every
foot and add 12 inches in it for every
foot so we'll just make a traditional
for loop here and we'll say into I
equals zero while I is less than the
feet and do I plus plus and then we'll
just two inches plus equals 12
so for every foot we're gonna add 12
inches to our little inches variable
there so we could do an else here and
say I don't know anything we could say
well obviously if this skips this first
one then it's negative yeah so we could
say something like who taught you
negative feet
whatever so that's just a random error
message you put whatever you want but
that's just a way you can do a little
notification we'll see how and next we
just wanted to go ahead and do the
conversion so after this we will have it
all in inches and down here below we can
go ahead and just convert that straight
into centimeters excuse me and to do
that well you probably have already
figured it out we could just declare a
float called final sense final
centimeters I'll make it a little more
this was it
final centimeters equals and this of
course is going to be inches x 2.5 4 but
we're not gonna use 2.54 we're going to
use this constant all right here and
we're you shouldn't use 12 right here we
should use this inches per foot and when
I format this it shouldn't fix my
spacing it just bus equals and she's
performing them now rather than do it
like this rather than have this in a for
loop you could just do something and
this might actually be better either
will work or you could do inches plus
equals and then you could do inches per
foot here times feet so you could just
do it all in one go here it'll be 12
times the number of feet and we're gonna
add that to the inches so that may be
better than a for loop either way it's
fine I think in this case and there we
go so we'll do it this way I kind of
like this way going through a for loop
it's a bit unnecessary and then we get
our final centimeters there's got to be
something here if you think about it cuz
well they could have entered I suppose
we should make sure they're not entering
and negative inches here too so we'll do
a [ __ ] all right now we're doing hand
and inches
creator than equal to zero so just to
make sure they don't put in a negative
that's often very important usually just
want to have a base checker on any
function you do to make sure you're not
taking in illegal variables or just
straight it straight up don't allow
negative or invalid stuff depends on
your program so that that will just take
care of that whole thing and of course
we want to return so it doesn't keep
going we do that that way it doesn't try
to do the rest of this
all right so that'll give us our final
centimeters and we're actually done this
is it I'm just gonna copy this down here
give it a new message the final well we
could we could format this a little bit
to make it a little nicer so we'll say
like let's see feet there's other ways
of formatting I might talk about later
but I'm just keeping it as simple as
possible right now hmm so we'll say X
amount of feet and X amount of inches
equals whatever centimeters we'll say it
like that equals final centimeters my
pair of apparently spelling this wrong
there we go
you know put a new line there and then
we'll return zero and we're done
yeah that should run so we'll go ahead
and just do our make and as you compile
it and run it it looks like we got a
return it doesn't like it's this return
zero and I'll just actually we will
return negative one to show an error
obviously it's not gonna really make a
difference here converting feet / inches
to centimeters enter feet I don't know
let's let's go with my height I'm about
six foot even so let's see how that
works
oopsie looks like I'm okay okay so this
this looks a little weird because I'm
converting all these feet to inches and
if it's just doubling up sort of so
obviously I don't really want to do that
so maybe I should take a new variable
for like new inches here so we'll say
int and inches of feet or something like
that and we'll start it out of zero and
we'll just put that here and then in
this final one will add both of them
together inches plus inches of feet so
add those together first and then we'll
multiply it and that should give us a
more correct output so six foot zero
and there we go so someone that is six
foot tall even is a hundred and eighty
two point eight eight centimeters tall
so that's apparently have time let's
just run one more test just to make sure
let's say we want to calculate two feet
in about five inches and see what that
turns out seventy-three yeah that's
about it that seems about right we could
just real quick go to Google here and do
a
feet in inches to centimeters and get a
little conversion thing here and say hey
if I'm 6 foot tall what is that
and it's 188 as you can see we've done
it correctly and we are done with this
question so thank you for tuning in to
this episode hopefully this helps you
guys out a little bit if you're new to
coding and trying to figure out how to
flow things and how to control variables
a little bit and we'll continue on in
the next episode have a good day